i did pull up this cnn article about the
karen trailer
and it's actually getting flack because
people are claiming they're just ripping
off get out
no the difference is get out was a good
movie yeah i mean i don't want to make
any i haven't seen obviously karen yet
the trailer doesn't look very good
but get out is a good movie about the
fears of assimilation
right it's the the fear that when you
assimilate into a culture
you lose your soul so that and it made
fun of white liberals which i got a kick
out of specifically
right we voted for obama but they're the
evil
i thought it was a kind of original
movie i got a kick out of it this
at least from the trailer i can't judge
the movie just looks like it's
it's falling into the myth of the evil
karen michael i've seen the trailer and
um
you're wrong this will be the citizen
kane of our generation oh my gosh
i love it did you see did you did you
show the photo of this i did
look at this oh dude it's so it's so
silly have you seen
um the hunt you know i wanted to but i
thought it didn't get pulled i thought
they they brought it back they they
ended up publishing they did publicly
i thought it was great it was good i
loved the idea the idea was well
so initially the hunt the trailer was
liberals kidnapping conservatives and
then hunting them
yeah and so my initial reaction was like
this is not the time
to be fanning the flames of this stuff
even donald trump was against it yeah i
i i changed my mind later on when i when
i was like
you know i shouldn't be against artful
depictions and i shouldn't play that
game about you know criticizing a movie
i haven't seen
and then it turns out when i watch the
movie it's actually really good yeah
well because it's
i don't think it's advocating that the
liberals go out and kidding they're the
bad guys they're the bad guys
so so it's actually like you've got
two different factions in this movie
snooty liberal elites
who are who are just they hate these
right-wing conspiracy theories so much
they want to kill them yeah
and then you have just dumb right-wing
conspiracy theorists where you're kind
of annoyed by them believing stupid
things
but they're not bad people this is goofy
people this is what's actually giving me
hope you know you say that steve bannon
says we're winning and
you know i i'll believe it when i see it
i've been you know i've been burned too
many times
folks but but the thing that does give
me hope
when these people of all different
colors parents of all different shapes
and sizes all around the country
show up to yell about critical race
theory i i see your point i think it's a
fair one that we shouldn't be arguing
with their language and that's a problem
sure and we can try to fix that but the
very fact
that these people are showing up these
ordinary americans
and then snooty elites radical elites
make
fun of them call them i don't you might
say deplorable irredeemable bitter
clinger
or whatever and you are further
alienating
the common sense american people from
this ruling class that absolutely
despises them
that is in real time a win for
conservatives yes
yes i think bannon's point is when these
children come back from school on day
one
and mom says what did you learn in
school that you're evil yeah
what yeah come again so i'm interested
though
um in the same in the same i do want to
talk about the loud and stuff
we'll get to that in a bit in terms of
movies like this this karen one
considering how like
really over the top the trailer is i'm
wondering if that'll have a similar
effect if if people start seeing movies
like this
where it display i mean this is this is
culture right in the movie
the hunt the liberal elites are the bad
guys i'm gonna a spoiler alert for
anybody who hasn't seen it you care if i
spoil it
spoil it the woman who's leading the
liberals
is kidnapping people because they were
spreading conspiracy theories about her
online and her friends
decided to help her out it turns out one
of the women who was kidnapped i think
she was like former military
and it was the wrong name so it turns
out is this innocent woman
was being harassed and they were trying
to kill her and she had nothing to do
with their politics
and i thought that was a really
interesting message based on what we're
seeing in the political landscape
regular people who don't care who don't
want to be involved are being forced
into it and accused of being racist and
being monsters
and now are being forced to fight for
their lives so when i see something like
this karen movie
a lot of people have already said karen
is like is a racial slur and you
shouldn't say it i've had people email
me like tim
don't use that word i mean i guess it
literally is a racial i'll say it yeah
you know but it is a racial slur it
references specifically like
white chicks yeah like white age yeah
well
becky is a young karen yeah exactly
that's what they've been saying
and so i i wonder though how many women
named karen yeah
had no no issues in politics didn't care
and then all of a sudden started feeling
bad
because people were insulting them based
on their name my friend's daughter's
name is isis
oh man he was named before the action
so there was a there was a meme of um
there there was a meme of of a mom yeah
and it was like a strict mom meme i
can't remember exactly what it was
and it was a woman like sitting down in
a photo that people used in these old
school memes with like the sunburst
behind it and it would say like
you know makes you clean your room and
then grounds you or something like that
and the woman in the photo was like
i'm not like that at all i'm like a nice
person and people are using this image
of me to represent something nasty
i have to wonder if hollywood keeps
making movies
that insult regular americans simply
because their name is karen
yeah i'm not saying they keep making
karen moves i'm saying if
if they do things like this that insult
and deride people is this the kind of
thing that's going to make someone go
i don't i don't feel good you're making
me feel bad i reject you
i i hope that that is the case because
it really it pains me to hear these
stories that you're mentioning of
you know someone who says well i i'm not
like that i'm not one of them i'm one of
the good
karens or whatever i'm the good isis uh
but
[Laughter]
but but the you have to come to the
realization
if you are in any way conservative and
by the way
it's not even on the racial politics if
you're just white if you're
black but you go along with the
conservative point of view you are
considered just as bad if not worse
you're saying if you're his
i guess if you're interested it's the
apostates that are a bigger threat
yeah and and i think what all these
people need to recognize is
the radical left hates you you are not
you can't charm your way out of it you
can't reason your way out of it
i know there's been a lot of talk now on
the internet about whether or not one
should engage in debates then there were
a certain
crowd or got ambushed by some libs or
something and there was there was
all of this debate me coward and all
this kind of stuff
i don't feel any compunction
about uh turning down a debate with
someone who hates me
because what's the what is the point of
that debate if i feel something
productive can come out of that i'll do
it but i don't feel any reason
well this is really fascinating
especially in terms of the crowder stuff
because
you know ethan klein is not a partic a
political individual
he was making comments about stephen
crowder i don't know how it started um
do you guys know how it started or what
what issue was what happened yeah so
uh ethan was saying that you don't need
to do any of your own research you just
trust the cdc whatever they say you
don't even have to do any homework and
his wife is just like uh-huh uh-huh
uh-huh
and i was like what what they're telling
they have like and crowder responded
yeah he had issues with that he's like
why would you tell people to not do
their own homework that doesn't make
sense
that's actually against uh uh i think
that's that might be against youtube's
rules
interesting to say not to questioning
well no it's
that's that's just to tell people how to
think about it
you need to tell uh youtube's rules are
that you can't discourage people from
seeking the expert uh medical opinions
so the cdc
might youtube might be like that's fine
i guess you can blindly follow them but
nobody
yeah no no but i think like youtube says
you can't discourage people from talking
to medical experts
for advice and saying you don't have to
do anything just follow the cdc
those aren't your doctors right so i
wonder if you should have debated ethan
well so
uh well ethan isn't a political figure
he's a drama grifter
like his whole thing is like i had never
heard of anything i had no
even the other guy i hadn't hadn't seen
he's interesting because they're kind of
under the radar but they're hugely
popular they just weren't like ever
front and center mainstream they kind of
came up on their
internet they get like millions of views
in their massive massive
so the issue though is this is why i
would say you got to be careful about
who you
debate like we're gonna we're gonna have
vosh back on okay uh you're familiar
with him he's like he's a leftist
youtube person i've heard of him i
haven't seen his stuff but i have heard
he's a he's a socialist or he's
i believe he's a socialist he's he's a
lefty uh gamer and then we're also
um planning on having on another uh a
few other leftist personalities
people who actually i think want to
engage in the uh
robust challenge of a good debate like i
think vosh loved it because he got a
bunch of clips where they said i was
dumb and of course we got
clips where they were like he's dumb but
i think we had a lot it was like four
hours yeah but there are some people
like the guy who ambushed uh stephen
crowder
this guy is a con man this guy's whole
shtick is to generate drama
and so the issue is steven crowder wants
to engage in a legitimate conversation
with ethan klein
ethan klein being a drama channel
yeah just turn the camera camera off
runs away and then says
here you go here's drama it's crowder
walked right into that one i think
crowder was correct to say hey ethan
let's let's let's let's talk
yeah and then uh when you release the
full audio you actually see they were
being very nice to each other and they
were like talking about family
and then ethan goes like haha i gotcha
ambushes crowder with a guy who's known
for not getting a lot of traffic yeah
and for trying as hard as possible to
get bigger channels to debate him so he
can get views
so crowder's like i have no obligation
to give you the time of day
you've been blacklisted by so many other
channels they refuse to talk to you and
i'll tell you this
behind the scenes a bunch of podcast
networks have already blacklisted
i'm not saying his name on purpose yeah
because he doesn't this is what he tries
to do he tries to use drama to get
attention
he's been blacklisted by a bunch of very
big podcasts even some more lefty ones
because he's viewed as a drama baiter
yeah who tries to get attention by just
causing fights and stuff like that yeah
but you know the right opens themselves
up to these kinds of attacks
when they go into the sort of the free
marketplace of ideas must always prevail
and we must always debate everything
with everybody and
we can never cancel or ostracize anybody
and i think
that's not true that's never been true i
i
not only do i have no obligation to
engage with somebody who's just a
shyster or some kind of jerk you know i
there's no re it's actually
counterproductive to do that
no one will learn anything no honesty
this is this is why i say um from this
point forward
i think it should be clear to everybody
ethan klein should be off
limits for any any uh legitimate
political uh podcast
of course the left will probably engage
with them because they're gonna be like
hey it's an opportunity to get views
and they like what he did but for
anybody who is
moderate anti-woke or wants to have a
legitimate conversation so this would be
like intellectual dark web types as well
as any other legitimate news news outlet
you you can't do it yeah not not with
somebody who's willing to poison
the political discourse for personal
gains what's you
you think about how dumb most debates
are it's really sad because
not that long ago you go back like 30
years there were pretty
popular debates that would air on tv or
certain areas burroughs was pretty
well-known yeah or you think firing line
or those kind of shows
and now they're just really dumb and
it's just like two heads screaming at
each other for five minutes on cable tv
or something right and i just think
i it's so degrading there's a political
rule that i learned years ago and i
think i violated it a couple times at my
own peril
never wrestle with a pig if you wrestle
with a pig you will both get dirty
but the pig will like it thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will
read your comments on the show don't
forget to like share subscribe and if
you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you